ja willkommen zur heutigen Sitzung wir
haben uns heute viel vorgenommen wir
werden heute
uns noch mal zu Beginn mit dem
begriffsnetz befassen das haben sie
schon die letzten Sitzung kennengelernt
und zwar möchte ich noch mal ein
bisschen erweitern wir haben die Person
wir können individuelle Person
unterscheiden von kollektiven wir können
das tun es gibt Argumente dafür es gibt
Argumente dagegen es gibt auch Argumente
dagegen dass wir uns als Person ansehen
ja es gibt Argumente die sagen wir sind
nur menschliche Tiere ja wir sind keine
Person es gibt keine Person sinnlos von
Personen als Dingen zu sprechen oder von
Personal identitätsbedingungen oder
sowas oder dass wir überhaupt wesentlich
Personen sein das kann man mit guten
Argumenten aber es gibt auch gute
Argumente dafür und sie haben in der
Umfrage gesagt 50% wir sind Personen und
50% wir sind keine Personen sondern
Tiere also wenn sie wissen es auch nicht
und ich weiß es eigentlich auch nicht
hundertprozentig so ist es in der
Philosophie es gibt gute Argumente dafür
dagegen dann kann man den Begriff der
Handlung diskutiert in dem Kontext den
Begriff des Willens und den
willensbegriff muss man unterscheiden
vom Begriff des Wunsches dann haben wir
den Begriff des Grundes ausführlich uns
angeschaut haben verschiedene
Bedeutungen von Gründen Unterschieden am
wichtigsten sind die normativen Gründen
also Gründe die guten Gründe und die
motivationalen Gründe die Gründe die uns
dann zu einer Handlung bewegen
und es gibt noch explikative Gründe
Gründe die uns eine Handlung
rechtfertigen lassen aber Kunde spielen
die rechtfertigen die Rolle kann man
sagen also was für Rollen spielen Gründe
man kann auch von einem kausalen Grund
sprechen das ist aber eine große
Diskussion sind Gründe Ursachen können
wir Gründe so verstehen wie
naturkausalität wie den Einschlag des
Blitzes der der Grund für das Brennen
des Waldes ist können wir auch so unsere
Handlung uns vorstellen dass da lauter
kausale Blitze sozusagen einschlagen
oder Folgen Gründe einer anderen Logik
das wird uns heute noch mehr
beschäftigen wenn es um die Frage geht
ob wir willensfrei sind also welche
Rolle der Determinismus spielt eine
Comic jetzt auch gleich zu welchen Grund
hat natürlich was mit Vernunft zu tun
wir haben auch noch die rationale Seite
die rationale Dimension von Gründen
behandelt Gründe die machen eine
Handlung verständlich und selbst aber
auch anderen Personen wenn wir sie
anderen Person verständlich machen dann
sind das explikativ oder rechtfertigen
gegründet man hat auch die Tendenz haben
den letzten Sitzung besprochen im
Nachhinein seine Handlungen zu
rationalisieren also möglichst zu
vermeiden dass der irgendwie allen
Schwäche vorkam oder Irrationalität das
ist ein Zug von allen Personen würde ich
mal behaupten die eigenen Handlungen zu
rationalisieren aber meine immer
rückblickend Kohärenz sein möchte wenn
man eine Geschichte von seinem Leben
erzählt dann möchte man ungern Lücken in
der Erzählung haben die Lücken sollen
irgendwie überbrückt werden durch Gründe
durch Ursachen durch eine Kohärenz durch
eine gewisse Folgerichtigkeit jeder
möchte ein folgerichtiges Leben leben
und selbst Misserfolge haben wir
jedenfalls die Tendenz sind für uns
häufig irgendwie doch versteckte Erfolge
also das scheint so eine Tendenz sein
unser Handeln auch im Nachhinein noch
ein bisschen zu stabilisieren sein jetzt
mal oder zumindest zu rationalisieren
und da spielen Gründe eine große Rolle
wir haben dann zwischen verschiedenen
Formen von Vernunft Unterschieden einmal
die instrumentelle Vernunft da war für
uns Immanuel ganz Begriff des
hypothetischen Imperativ sehr zentral
und dann noch die moralische Vernunft
und zwar sind hier die kategorischen
imperative relevant nach Immanuel
Kantner Immanuel Kanzler unsere Vernunft
gibt uns nicht nur das Mittel zum Zweck
also ein Instrumentalist
Verständnis eines Operation der Vernunft
wenn irgendwas erreichen möchten dann
müssen wir dieses Mittel dafür ergreifen
dass wir Instrument telefonieren die
hypothetischen imperative gelten ja auch
nur in einer bestimmten Bedingung sind
bedingt wenn ich dieses Ziel habe mein
Beispiel bei den Konstanz Halbmarathon
in einer guten Zeitlauf unter 2 Stunden
dann muss ich das und das und lassen was
tun das liegt mir die Klugheit nahe ja
meine Vernunft Telefonist die legten
nahe dann musst du das und das und das
tun da gibt's ein riesen
Trainingsprogramm und so weiter und so
fort das ist Instrument telefonieren
wenn ich hingegen jetzt moralische
vernünftig anschaut dann spielt dann
nicht individuelle Ziele eine Rolle also
die Konstanz Halbmarathon gut zu laufen
sondern unser Handeln generell nicht nur
das Handeln oder die Aktion die jetzt
eine sportliches Ereignis betrifft
sondern unser Handel generell und das
sagt zumindest kann gebietet die
Vernunft aus sich selbst heraus er
spricht von einer reinen praktischen
Vernunft also nicht empirisch orientiert
an individuellen Zwecken sind die
Vernunft generell als solche was auch
immer das ist kann man von uns überhaupt
davon sprechen dass sie etwas tut und
dass sie etwas gebietet das wäre ja
wieder das Problem wie bei John Block
dass der Wille etwas tut ne also diese
Rede ist problematisch jedenfalls kann
man für es zu sprechen die Vernunft
gebietet machen kann als praktische
Funktion als reinigt und tierisch
sondern als generelle Vernunft dass wir
das und das tun sollen bzw nicht tun
sollen z.B hat mir diskutiert wir sollen
nicht lügen und zwar kategorisch nicht
nur unter bestimmten
vor Gericht sind soll man nicht lügen
und wenn wir bei einer guten Freundin
beim guten Freund eingeladen sind und
der Kuchen schmeckt uns nicht dann
dürfen wir lügen wenn uns die Freundin
fragt hat er geschmeckt das wäre die
notlügel ja Sie können die beliebige
andere Dinge überlegen ja
also das ist die Frage sind Notlügen
erlaubt wir haben darüber diskutiert und
gute Argumente auch für das generelle
lügenverbot gefunden es gibt natürlich
wie bei allem der Philosophie auch gute
Argumente für die Notlüge ja aber kann
sagt wir sollten nicht lügen und er sagt
die Vernunft gebietet das auch eine
spannende Frage ob sowas wie moralische
von uns überhaupt gibt wir haben darüber
abgestimmt hier also unsere Meinungen
praktisch mal erfasst Meinungen sind
eine Sache Argumente sind die andere
Sache wir haben uns Argumente angeschaut
von David jung hat gesagt sowas wie
moralische Vernunft moralisch Gebieten
der Vernunft gesagt
schottische empiristische Philosoph die
gibt es einfach nicht die Wille der
Wille und die Vernunft die Affekte und
die vernünftige treten gar nicht in ein
Konkurrenzverhältnis das geht gar
Immanuel kann den Gegensatz die Vernunft
kann mit den Affekten kämpfen die
Vernunft in uns kann Affekte oder
Neigungen Gefühle überwinden weil sie
sogar selbst sein eigenes Gefühl
hervorbringt darauf kann man doch zu
sprechen zum Thema moralische Motivation
nämlich das vernünftige Gefühl der
Achtung also die Vernunft tritt nicht
nur sagt kein mit den Affekten in ein
Konkurrenzverhältnis wenn es um die
Bestimmung unseres Willens geht und die
Motivation
sondern sie produziert selbst machen
eigenes Gefühl vernünftige Gefühle das
wird uns auch noch anschauen vor der
Frage wie wir handeln wie wir zum
Handeln motiviert werden das ist ein
riesen Thema hier kann man schön
diskutieren dann haben wir die Vernunft
abgegrenzt von der wellenschwäche oder
vernünftiges handelt von will schwachen
Handeln abgegrenzt in den letzten
Sitzung noch mal drüber diskutieren was
gibt es für konkrete Beispiele für
villenschwaches Handeln gibt es
überhaupt willenschwäche oder ist das
nur eine Erfindung von seltsamen
Philosophen und Philosophen die sonst
nichts zu tun haben ja also
willenschwäche wird bestritten von
einigen philosophierenden dass das
überhaupt gibt manche sagen das ist ein
Scheinproblem das ist eigentlich gar
kein Problem man tut nur so als ob es
eins sein wir haben uns mit Donald
Davidson befasst der hat dafür einige
Argumente aber der sagt dann wenn ja
auch das ist irgendwie ein Paradox ja
wir haben uns wie gesagt Beispiele
belegt ein Beispiel dass ich hatte waren
aber Versionen die uns zu einer Handlung
bringen obwohl wir eigentlich der
Meinung sind dass das keine guten Gründe
sind aber Versionen wir hatten das
Beispiel weiß ich auch sehr Treffen fand
mit dem länger schlafen länger liegen
bleiben im Bett dass man noch mal auf
den Wecker Haut obwohl man eigentlich
genau weiß das bringt nichts aber
irgendwie mache ich dann halt doch ja
also Sie können sich verschiedene
Beispiele hier überlegen das Phänomen
der willenschwäche sofern sie der
Überzeugung sind das ist das gibt dann
haben wir jetzt einen neuen Bereich
aufgemacht nämlich den Bereich der
Freiheit und darum soll es auch heute
gehen erstmal noch die Unterscheidung
habe ich jetzt hier nicht einbezogen man
kann unterscheiden zwischen positiven
und negativer Freiheit positive freiheit
ist die Freiheit so etwas und negative
freiheit ist die Freiheit von etwas ganz
allgemein hilft immer das hilft immer
sehr viel so sich der Freiheit
anzunehmen und jetzt können wir aber
noch grundsätzliche Unterscheidung noch
wichtiger finde ist in der Scheidung
zwischen Handlungsfreiheit und
Willensfreiheit wir haben den letzten
Sitzung uns mit der Handlungsfreiheit
befasst mit Argumenten für die
Handlungsfreiheit und gegen die Willen
also es gibt viele philosophierende die
sagen wir haben eigentlich gar keine
willensfrei sein unsinniger Begriff das
gibt's gar nicht der Wille kann gar
nicht frei gen werden sondern nur
letztendlich der handelnde Mensch oder
vielleicht die Handlung aber nicht der
Wille dann werden wir heute nachdem wir
uns noch ein bisschen mit der
Handlungszeit befassen uns ganz
verstärkt auf die Willensfreiheit
beziehen und in diesem Zusammenhang ist
auch der Begriff der Autonomie ganz
zentral Autonomie so sie kann jetzt
schon sagen bedeutet so viel wie
Selbstgesetzgebung ich komme noch ein
bisschen mehr auf diesen Begriff zu
sprechen auch anhand der Philosophie von
Immanuel handelt und wie bei allem kann
man jetzt hier noch mal die Freiheit
kontrastieren mit der determination oder
sind das sind
Perspektiven auf die Freiheit
determination Notwendigkeit und
Indifferenz und man kann sich jetzt
fragen wie verhält sich die Freiheit
Handlungsfreiheit oder Willensfreiheit
zum
Phänomen
bestimmt ist bestimmt ist so
Notwendigkeit oder zum Zwang von
Paulchen ist der
Begriff dafür oder zur Indifferenz oder
auch zum äquilibrismus wir haben das
bestimmt als diese Waage die im
Gleichgewicht steht oder auch der Esel
der vor zwei genau gleich großen
Heuballen steht und am Ende verhungert
weil er keinen Grund hat den einen
Heuballen dem anderen vorzuziehen
darüber haben wir diskutiert ob man da
überhaupt Gründe brauchen den ein oder
anderen Heuballen vorzuziehen wenn er
doch Hunger hat dann ist es doch egal
wie ja aber ist dann die Handlung wenn
man das überhaupt zur Handlung nennen
kann dass der Esel ein heuball ist ist
die Aktion ist überhaupt dann äh gut
begründet sie vielleicht nur willkürlich
wir können es natürlich auch uns selbst
verdienen bei einer großen zwei Bergen
großer
Schokoladentafeln oder was auch immer
vorstellen wenn wir hungrig sind und
sonst nichts haben also verträgt sich
Freiheit mit Indifferenz mit
equilibrismus mit Notwendigkeit oder mit
der termination das ist spannend weil
wir jetzt heute am Ende der Sitzung uns
mit den zwei Positionen des
kompatibilismus befassen werden und des
inkompatibilismus ich sage ein bisschen
was vorweg wir werden uns damit aber
ganz intensiv befassen noch
kompatibilismus heißt freiheit sei es
jetzt Handlungsfreiheit oder
Willensfreiheit ist mit determination
vereinbar wir können also determiniert
sein und zum Handel und sind trotzdem
Freude vielleicht gerade deshalb und im
kompatibilismus heißt Freiheit oder
Handlungszeit beträgt sich nicht mit der
determination und dann gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten warum verträgt er sich
nicht vielleicht deswegen weil der der
terminismus war ist und wir haben also
einfach nicht frei sind
handlungsförderung vor allem Willen oder
weil der terminismus falsch ist weil es
gar stimmt das alles in der Welt
vollständige terminiert ist durch die
Naturgesetze weil es vielleicht unter
bestimmte Bereiche gibt weil vielleicht
in unserem Gehirn gewisse Quanten
Zustände eine Rolle spielen die wir sie
alle wissen nicht der terministisch
erfassbar sind sodass also nach anderen
Auffassung die man dann libertarierismus
nennen wir frei sind beide der
terminismus falsch ist da stellt sich
natürlich wieder das Problem ja wenn wir
annehmen dass die Determinismus falsch
ist müssen wir dann sowas wie
Indifferenz sein in der terminismus
annehmen aber ist in der terminismus am
Ende nicht so viel wie bloßer Zufall ist
unser gar nicht begründet ja wir kommen
darauf noch mehr zu sprechen sie sehen
man kann sie hier schön lang handeln und
wir machen dann auch eine Umfrage ob sie
glauben sie können Sie jetzt schon
bisschen Gedanken machen dass wir
willensfrei sind jetzt nicht
handlungsfrei den die meisten würden
sagen wir sind handlungsfrei aber fangen
sie schon mal ein bisschen an sich
Gedanken zu machen bei allen Argumenten
die sie jetzt noch mal hören werden ob
wir willensfrei sind also ob unser Wille
frei genannt werden kann so viel zum
begriffsnetz und sie sehen ganz recht
ist noch eine große weiße Fläche frei
die wartet darauf in den nächsten
Vorlesungen weiter gefüllt zu werden
also wir werden es noch mit anderen
Themen zu tun haben wir werden es mit
Sprachhandlungen zu tun haben da sage
ich was dazu das merkt in der nächsten
Woche behandeln wir können auch mit
unserer Sprache nicht nur mit unseren
Händen dann wird ein weiteres Thema die
Frage nach der Normativität sein was ist
überhaupt die Gesetzlichkeit die
Verbindlichkeit die unsere Handeln
betrifft normative Gründe hatten wir
schon bisschen kennengelernt wir werden
uns mit der Rolle von Emotionen befassen
welche Rolle spielt Emotionen ganz unser
Handeln und wir werden uns auch fragen
was eigentlich gutes Handeln ist und was
schlechtes oder Böses haben das ist ein
aus und diese Begriffe werden wir auf
dieser rechten Seite noch ihren Ort
finden
ja jetzt würde ich noch meine kurze
[Musik]
Frage runter einbauen dass sie dazu noch
Fragen stellen können
ja in diesem Schema werde ich noch den
Begriff der Willkür verorten da kann
sich jeder auch überlegen wo der denn
seine richtige Position haben soll jetzt
geht's weiter und jetzt machen wir ein
Rückblick auf die nächste Sitzung auf
die letzte Sitzung da hatten wir es mit
dem Thema Handlungsfreiheit zu tun ich
fasse noch mal kurz zusammen
Handlungszeit heißt einfach tun können
was man will sie haben sich ein Wille
gewisse triebeneigungen was auch immer
begehrungen und wenn Sie tun können was
sie Behren oder was Sie wollen dann sind
sie handlungsfall häufig würde sagt man
so umgangssprachlich dann bin ich doch
willenfrei aber das ist nicht derselbe
also Handlungszeit
unterschieden werden
weil man Willensfreiheit jetzt ein
bisschen paradoxermaßen oder paradox so
beschreiben kann wollen können was man
will oder wollen was man
begehrt also den Willen selbst bestimmen
zu können sein Willen selbst bestimmen
zu können und nicht nur den Willen in
eine Handlung übersetzen zu können und
das ist etwas paradox weil wenn ich
etwas will dann will ich doch was dann
muss ich doch den Willen nicht mehr
wollen das ist doch unnötig ja ich bin
doch zu einem Wille gekommen und jetzt
geht's darum dass der will in die
Handlung geführt wird und nicht darum
den Willen zu wollen wenn ich ein Wille
habe dann will ich was Punkt aus warum
soll ich dir noch mal wollen wollen oder
wollen können oder was auch immer da
gibt es eben diese Intuition das
man annehmen könnte dass wir uns unseren
Willen erst zu eigen machen müssen weil
wir in unserem wollen die den
fremdgestimmt sein könnte
manipuliert sein können es kann sein wir
haben uns irgendwelche Wünsche
begehrungen
und beim genaueren Betrachten stellen
wir fest das ist eigentlich gar nicht
mein Bild glauben nur dass das mein
Beruf ja ich bin beeinflusst worden
durch bestimmte Umstände der
Meinungsbildung der Willensbildung bin
ich beeinflusst worden das heißt es ist
eine sehr löbliches Unternehmen nämlich
eigentlich fast ein Unternehmen was auch
im Kontext der Aufklärung steht nämlich
sich über sein Willen klar zu werden
sein will kritisch zu betrachten will
ich das eigentlich wirklich und das ist
so die Intuition dahinter zu sagen wir
sollten noch eine andere Freiheit ein
noch grundsätzliche Freiheit neben der
Handlungsfreiheit annehmen jetzt hatten
wir John Block behandelt John Lock ist
ein empiristischer Philosoph ein
englischer Philosoph ausziehen 17
Jahrhundert und er hatte in seinem Werk
im es standing aus dem Jahr 1690 hatte
er die These vertreten
der Wille ist nicht frei oder unfrei
er sagt meines Erachtens ist die
richtige Fragestellung nicht ist der
Wille frei sondern ist der Mensch frei
das ist das generelle Problem wie sollen
wir von unseren Vermögen sprechen sollen
wir sagen die Vernunft tut etwas ich
habe vorhin so gesprochen die Vernunft
nach Kant habe ich gesagt die stellt
dann absolutes Gebot auf das Sitten
gesetzt den kategorischen Imperativ
gut die Vernunft das wirklich oder tut
das nicht viel mehr der Mensch
durchliefern oder mit Hilfe also wie
sollen wir von Vermögen die Wille von
uns
Wahrnehmung wie sollen wir davon
sprechen ja mir sagt eben jetzt der
Wille ist eigentlich nur eine Kraft und
eine Kraft ist eigentlich eine
Eigenschaft wenn ich sage etwas ist
kräftig dann spreche ich die Kraft als
Eigenschaft eine Person zu und ich
spreche nicht von der Kraft als einem
Subjekt sagt zu weit nun diese Kraft
reicht zu handeln oder nicht zu handeln
je nachdem ob die Entscheidung seines
Denkens die ein oder andere Möglichkeit
bevorzugt so weit ist der Mensch frei
es lässt sich schwerlich angeben sagte
weiter wie wir uns einwiesen noch freier
vorstellen können als ist dann ist wenn
es fähig ist zu tun was es will also es
reicht doch völlig wenn wir tun können
was wir wollen was ist denn da noch mehr
nötig dass Sie mir doch perfekt sein wir
haben ein Bild
so wirklich unser Wille kann man sich
fragen ob ich mein Windeln ich habe
irgendwie ein Wunsch Begehungen ein
wenig Form und der strebt seine Handlung
der möchte in Erfüllung gehen oder Wille
der Wille nicht nur der Wunsch der Wille
zudem wir uns fest entschieden haben und
dann kann ich das auch tun super ist
doch alles perfekt warum soll ich da
jetzt noch nach mehr Fragen
ja das ist eben dieses Problem
es gibt jetzt hier ein Problem wenn man
den Menschen in diesem Sinne Freiheit
zuschreibt indem man die Tätigkeit des
Wollens von seinem Willen abhängig sein
ist also wenn man jetzt doch noch
Willensfreiheit annehmen möchte und
nicht nur Handlungsfreiheit also wenn
die Tätigkeit des Wollens von seinen
Willen abhängig ist ja Willen ist ja
unseren Willen bestimmt wollen können
was man will
wenn man das tut muss man außerdem noch
einen zweiten woraufgehenden Willen
annehmen der die Akte dieses Willens
bestimmt und einen dritten der wieder
diesen bestimmt und so weiter im
infinitum denn sobald eine aufführt der
eine aufführt könnte die Handlung des
letzten Willens nicht frei sein das
Problem der Willen ist dass sie
natürlich unseren Wille der den Wille
bestimmt immer noch bestimmen müssen und
so weiter und so fort wir kommen
unendlichen Regression darauf hatte
schon Harry friend für ein bisschen
hingewiesen mit den volition zweiter
Stufe wenn die nicht ganz einheitlich
sind dann brauchen wir vielleicht
volition Dritter Stufe und vielleicht
volition 4 Stufe und das führt sagt am
Ende zu einer Zerstörung der Person also
es ist unsinnig den Wille bestimmen zu
wollen will endlich weil dann müsste man
den Willen bestimmt und so weiter und so
fort wir haben kein Ende in sich und
wenn wir ein Ende annehmen würden dann
wäre dieses Ende nur will weil wir
einfach keine Lust mehr haben weiter
unseren Willen nicht zu bestimmen so das
ist einfach das Problem dann sagt jetzt
John Lock es gibt aber trotzdem so eine
Art von Willensfreiheit und zwar sagte
da der Geist die Erfahrung zeigt in den
meisten Fällen die Kraft besitzt bei der
Verwirklichung oder Befriedigung eines
Wunsches inne zu halten und mit allen
anderen Wünschen der Rhein nach ebenso
zu verfahren so hat er auch die Freiheit
ihre Objekte zu betrachten sie von allen
Seiten zu prüfen und gegen andere
abzusehen ja also wir können uns unsere
Wünsche begehrungen die letzten
Tendenzen erstmal aus einer gewissen
Distanz betrachten
und dann uns in einer gewissen ruhigen
Situation dafür entscheiden wir können
Sie abwägen wir können eine reflexive
Distanz zu unserem Willen treten und das
ist eigentlich sogar Willensfreiheit
also streng genommen ist es gar nicht so
dass John lockt sagt es gibt keine
Willensfreiheit sondern das was er hier
beschreibt ist eigentlich ganz ähnlich
dem was Harry Frank wird beschreibt wenn
er sagt dass wir volition zweite Stufe
entwickeln wir treten zurück vor unserem
wünschen Begehrung und Willen Tendenzen
und überlegen uns was wir eigentlich
wollen mit was wir uns identifizieren
wollen
handlungswirksam ne also eigentlich
hatte hier schon so ein bisschen was wie
wenn es Freiheit drin
ja also es geht um die Prüfung unseres
wallets unsere Willens Tendenzen
und dann sagt er weiter hier in dieser
Distanz zu unserem Willen scheint mir
die Quelle aller Freiheit zu liegen
hierhin scheint das zu bestehen was dann
meines Erachtens unzutreffend den freien
will also wir sollten nur so vom freien
Willen von der bild-zeit reden in dem
Sinne dass wir zurücktreten können vor
den unmittelbaren wünschen begehrungen
Neigungen und Sie prüfen können und sie
abwägen können was spricht dafür das ist
für ihn Blindheit aber nicht deine
solche Rede die sagt der Wille ist frei
oder der Wille tut etwas weil das wäre
eine
unberechtigte
Personifizierung oder
substantialisierung des Willens die
eigentlich nur eine Kraft ein
Eigenschaft oder sogar auch nur eine
Relation sagt ja bei Kräfte ja immer
zwischen verschiedenen Substanzen wirken
ja also sie kennen die verschiedenen
Kräfte die es gibt in der Physik starke
Kraft schwache Kraft elektromagnetische
Kraft und so weiter und so fort die
bestehen ja immer zwischen Dingen
Teilchen oder was auch immer zwischen
Planeten wie auch immer das heißt man
kann eigentlich von Kräften wenn man sie
jetzt auf die Freiheit bezieht nicht so
sprechen dass sie Dinge sind das wäre
eine Verdinglichung der Freiheit
ja das war jetzt so ein Rückblick wir
machen noch eine kleine
diskussionseinheit darüber ob Sie noch
Fragen gibt und dann fahren wir fort mit
dem eigentlichen Thema der heutigen
Sitzung nämlich der Willensfreiheit
ja nachdem wir uns mit dem Thema der
Handlungsfreiheit befasst haben gehen
wir über zum Thema der Willensfreiheit
und ich sagte schon willenseit ist ein
sehr anspruchsvoller Freiheitsbegriff
warum weil er eben die Handlungsfreiheit
noch mal tiefer fast wir müssen nicht
nur tun können was wir wollen sondern
wir müssen auch sicherstellen dass unser
Wille der uns Regel ist und wir unseren
Willen selbst gebildet haben und
natürlich muss zur Willensfreiheit am
Ende noch die handlungszeiten zukommt
weil es bringt nichts wenn wir nur
willensfrei sind das ist unbefriedigend
weil wir da nicht tun können wir bleiben
die Tränen uns nur um uns selbst also
Willensfreiheit besteht im Gegensatz zur
Handlungsfreiheit darin unseren Willen
selbst zu bestimmen selbst bestimmen zu
können es gilt also nicht nur zu tun was
man will sondern unser Wille muss
kritisch geprüft und
reflektiert werden dann Lock hatte das
schon ein bisschen angedeutet die mir
gesagt hat wir treten zurück man nennt
das die Inhibition
oder auch die Aufschiebung die
Aufschiebung ich halte mal inne und rede
zurück und der liberiere ich reflektiere
noch mal über das was ich jetzt glaube
zu wollen und das ist eine reflexive
Haltung und die wird häufig auch mit
einer vernünftigen Haltung gleichgesetzt
dem Thema Willensfreiheit liegt die
Überzeugung zugrunde dass wir selbst die
Ursache unseres Wollens oder willens
sein müssen und nicht nur unsere
Handlung als auch unser Wille muss
irgendwie uns selbst zur Verfügung
stehen es könnte nämlich sein dass
unsere manipuliert wurde und der gar
nicht unser eigener Wille ist
das eigentlich will ich das eigentlich
im Grunde hier geht es wirklich was ist
eigentlich das eigene Ich was will ich
im tiefsten innerer was macht mein
Identität aus und danach muss ich der
Wille dann richten damit meine freie
Handlung ist
und hier spielt der Begriff der
Autonomie eine große Rolle wir müssen
uns selbst die Gesetze unseres Handelns
und Rollens geben also die Gesetze
unseres Handelns die stammen nicht von
außen nicht von
außerhalb des nennt man Heteronomie
Heteronomie wir kommen doch auf
Autonomie Heteronomie bedeutet
fremdgesetzgebung oder Fremdsteuerung
wie auch immer Gesetzgebung sondern
müssen sicherstellen dass die Regel den
unserer wollen nachdem wir unseren
ausrichten dass die Regeln von uns
selbst stammen dass wir uns also selbst
die Regeln geben nachdem wir unser
Wollen und Handeln bestimmen und das ist
natürlich ein sehr komplexer Gedanke
deswegen wird Autonomie häufig im
Zusammenhang mit Willensfreiheit
diskutiert wir kommen jetzt aber noch
genauer darauf zu sprechen was das ist
und es gibt natürlich eine Frage
inwiefern sind wir frei uns die Gesetze
des Wollens und Handelns zu geben wie
können wir uns vorstellen dass wir uns
selbst die Gesetze das wollen zu
Handelns geben
Immanuel Kant hat darauf eine Antwort
gefunden und wir gehen auch gleich auf
hinein zunächst mal möchte ich noch mal
auf Harry Frankfurt Zurückgehen der
nämlich eine der prominentesten
gegenwärtigen Theorien der
Willensfreiheit entwickelt hat
und zwar in Kontrast zur
Handlungsfreiheit bestimmt
Willensfreiheit analog zur
Handlungsfreiheit er sagt folgendes wenn
wir fragen ob eine Person einen freien
Willen hat dann fragen wir nicht danach
ob Sie in der Lage ist ihre Wünsche
erste Stufe in die Tat umzusetzen das
wäre die Frage ob sie frei ist zu tun
was ihr gefällt
das ist die Handlungsfreiheit die Frage
nach der Willensfreiheit betrifft nicht
das Verhältnis zwischen dem was jemand
tut und dem was er tun möchte sondern
sie betrifft die Wünsche selber möchte
ich diese Wünsche haben und nicht nur
kann ich sie ausführen in die Handlung
und jetzt kommt es entscheidende Zitat
es scheint mir naheliegen und auch
nützlich die Frage ob jemand ein freien
will hat möglichst genau und Analogie zu
der Frage zu konstruieren ob jemand
Handlungsfreiheit genießt nun ist
Handlungsfreiheit jedenfalls im groben
Umriss die Freiheit zu tun was man tun
möchte
entsprechend besagt die Behauptung dass
jemand sich eines freien Willens erfreut
jedenfalls Gruppen wissen dass er frei
ist zu wollen was er wollen möchte
genauer heißt das dass er frei ist den
Willen zu haben den er haben möchte
genauso wie die Frage nach der Zeit eine
Handlung darauf zieht ob sie auch die
Handlung ist wieder betreffende
ausführen möchte so bezieht sich die
Frage nach der willensweite darauf ob
der Wille den eine hat der Wille ist den
haben möchte also Handlungsfreiheit und
Willen werden ganz analog zueinander
konstruiert kann ich tun was ich will
kann ich wollen was ich wollen möchte
kann ich mein Bild selbst bestimmen kann
ich meinen Willen selbst formen also das
ist noch mal aus demselben Aufsatz von
Harry Franco den aus dem ich ihn schon
mal Zitate gebracht hat die Bestimmung
der willensfeier ich finde es sehr zutra
also wir müssen auch unseren Willen
selbst noch mal reflektieren können
jetzt komme ich auf allen wieder etwas
älteren Philosophen zu sprechen nämlich
auf gottfried Wilhelm Leibnitz der hat
ähnlich wie schon gesagt vor allem im 17
Jahrhundert lebt der beiden
Zeitgenossenschaft und er war nicht nur
ein Zeitgenossen von John locker sondern
er hat auch mit John lockt eine
Diskussion geführt also er hat auch
diese Schrift von John lockt reagiert in
der indem er eine Art von Dialog
durchgeführt hatten einen Wert also eine
Person in seinem Dialog ist ja schon
locker oder die Willens die
handlungsfreiheitsposition und er stellt
diese Handlungsfreiheit Dialog Person
eine Person entgegen die die
Willensfreiheit stark machen auch das
können wir mal Auszügen vielleicht im
Tutorium lesen wenn Interesse besteht
und das ist natürlich sehr clever wir
das auch schon auf literarische Ebene
machen so sah der gute Mann aus sie
sehen das war eine Person der Barockzeit
wo man noch so frisiert waren und
er hat jetzt ein Berg geschrieben neu
Abhandlung über den menschlichen
Verstand natürlich ursprünglich auf
Französisch dieser Zeit haben die
meisten Philosophen auf Französisch
geschrieben aus dem Jahr 1704 er möchte
also im Gegensatz zu John locks Theorie
der handlungsfrei für die
Willensfreiheit argumentieren also
Leibnitz ist eine der größten
verstärkten Vertreter der
Willensfreiheit er nimmt jetzt drei
Bedingungen für die Willen also
Handlungszeit ist eigentlich ziemlich
einfach tun können was man will wenn es
Zeit ist es nicht ganz so einfach und
zwar sagt der Kontingenz ist eine der
Bedingung für Willen Zeit Kontingenz ist
nicht Notwendigkeit sagt er und die
nicht in Differenz also entscheidend ist
einfach dass es möglich ist aber nicht
notwendig ja was notwendig ist ist auch
möglich
ja und er sagt es soll jedenfalls nicht
notwendig sein und nicht unmöglich
also Kontingenz kennen Sie auch aus
anderen Kontexten wenn man sagt das war
zufällig das war Kontingent es war nicht
notwendig das hätte auch ganz anders
sein also sie müssen Kontingent so
verstehen dass es einfach nicht
notwendig ist aber auch nicht unmöglich
ist das ist einfach ein
wirklichkeitsspielraum ist am besten
werden sich das einfach als Abgrenzung
von der Notwendigkeit ne
und jetzt bringt ein Beispiel was er
damit meint er sagt nämlich die
geometrischen und metaphysischen
Konsequenzen enthalten eine Nötigung
messesité auf Französisch die physischen
und moralischen Konsequenzen aber machen
nur geneigt ohne zu nötig also er meint
mit Notwendigkeit jetzt folgendes also
Kontingenz meint den Ausschluss von
Notwendigkeit Notwendigkeit so Leibnitz
beträgt sich auf gar keine Weise mit
Willensfreiheit ne
hatte ja auch die Notwendigkeit
jedenfalls für seine Handlungsfreiheit
ausgeschlossen
geometrische und metaphysische
Konsequenzen die nötig ja was ist denn
eine geometrische Notwendigkeit da denkt
Leibnitz sehr mathematisch wie zum
Beispiel ein logischen Schluss oder eine
eine geometrische Konstruktion der Satz
ist Pythagoras ne sie kennen den alle
dass sich der so verhält das ist
verleibnitz eine geometrische
Notwendigkeit der Satz des Pythagoras
der gilt zwingend für alle
entsprechenden Dreiecke und da gibt's
keine Diskussion drüber da kann man
nicht sagen ja aber es spricht ein Grund
dafür dass der Winkel dann doch 91 Grad
ist und und die Summe der
Hypotenuse das ist doch anders ist er da
gibt's nichts zu diskutieren das ist
auch nicht zufälligerweise so sagt
sondern das ist notwendigerweise so das
ist in der Struktur der Geometrie
halten und metaphysische Konsequenzen
ebenso da müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr
darauf eingehen nur dass sie mal wissen
also logische auch logische Folgerungen
und so weiter sind notwendig die ergeben
sich zwingend auseinander und das sind
jetzt nach Leibnitz
Notwendigkeiten und so dürfen wir uns
Freiheit nicht vorstellen in diesem
Sinne dieser zwingende Notwendigkeit es
gibt aber noch physische und moralische
Konsequenzen also Verhältnisse zwischen
verschiedenen Ereignissen und von den
sagten zum Beispiel moralischen
Kontexten dass die nur geneigt machen
das ist im Klinik Inklination die machen
nur geneigt ohne dass sie uns nötigen
und mit dieser mit diesem geneigt machen
meint er dass sie uns bestimmen dass sie
uns determinieren aber nicht
netzesitieren also Leibniz unterscheidet
zwischen der Notwendigkeit und der
determination das kann man sich fragen
ist das nicht genau dasselbe
Notwendigkeit und der termination landen
würde sagen nein wir kommen noch genauer
drauf zu sprechen
es gibt verschiedene Arten von
Bestimmung es gibt notwendige
Bestimmungen und es gibt
nicht notwendig bestimmen nämlich
Kontingente Bestimmung die uns nur
geneigt macht aber nicht nötig das heißt
in bestimmten Kontexten zum Beispiel
moralischen Kontexten und dann handeln
sind wir bestimmt aber so bestimmt dass
die Bestimmung Kontingent ist also dass
sie nicht notwendig ist ich lasse es
einfach mal dahingestellt wir können
gleich noch ein bisschen mehr drauf zu
sprechen kommen so sagt jedenfalls dann
ist weitere Bedingungen für willensweit
ist die Intelligenz oder die
deliberation von der sagt leibnis der
Zeit die Seele der Willen also das ist
praktisch so der der absolute Grund und
hier wäre jetzt so meine Übersetzung das
sind vernünftige Gründe ja also Gründe
müssen einfach auch in der
willensverhalten eine Rolle spielen wir
müssen der vibrieren wir müssen
zurücktreten für unseren Willen wir
müssen abwägen was spricht dafür und was
spricht dagegen und es ist noch nicht zu
Ende hat nämlich drei Bedingungen für
die Willen auch noch die Spontanität das
ist die selbstuhr sichtlichkeit ne also
das ist zum Beispiel zu einer dieser
Punkte wo man sagen kann damit schließt
er dieses
manipulationsproblem aus der
Handlungsfreiheit weil wir selbst
verursachen sind wenn sie spontan was
machen Spontanität kommt aus dem
Lateinischen heißt letztendlich aus
eigenem Antrieb also von selbst aus von
sich aus man ist letztendlich Urheber
Urheber dieser Handlung oder auch des
Willens der Willensbildung diese drei
Bedingungen Kontingenz also nicht
Notwendigkeit
Intelligenz vernünftige Gründe Abwägung
und Spontanität Disney 3 Bedingungen
starke Anforderungen extrem starke
Anforderungen die bleiben hier für die
Existenz von Willensfreiheit anführt es
geht noch ein bisschen weiter und dann
können wir darüber diskutieren
nach Leibnitz sind wir jetzt vollständig
der terminiert das habe ich ja schon
gesagt ne wir sind also im kriminiert
aber nicht nett wir sind vollständig
determiniert aber dennoch Willen
und warum sagt bleiben dass wir
vollständig definiert sind weil Leibnitz
dem Satz des zureichenden Grundes folgt
der Satz ist zu reichenden gründes ist
ein ganz wichtiges Prinzip ein
metaphysisches Prinzip was allem auf der
Welt nach Leibnitz zugrunde liegt alles
hat einen hinreichenden Grund alles hat
seinen Grund es gibt nichts in der Welt
was nicht einen Grund hat ja jetzt kann
man sich überlegen was spricht dafür so
ein Prinzip anzunehmen ja ich würde
schon mal sagen auf alle deswegen weil
natürlich immer die Ursache wissen wir
wollen immer weiter fragen können dürfen
warum war das so
alles hat seinen Grund und das ist
vielleicht jetzt ein ganz wichtiges
Prinzip und diesen Prinzip untersteht
auch unsere Willensfreiheit auch unsere
Willensfreiheit muss ihre Gründe haben
unsere willensweit ist nicht so zu
verstehen dass sie außerhalb dem Raum
der Gründe das ist so eine Redeweise die
sich eingebürgert hat Ausgang von einem
analytischen Philosophen namens
hat von dem Raum der Gründe gesprochen
also wir befinden uns immer in
Kontexten der Begründung der
Ursächlichkeit jetzt mal allgemein
gesagt es gibt nichts was keinen Grund
hat oder von dem man den Grund nicht
herausfinden könnte man kann natürlich
sagen ich weiß den Grund von dieser
Sache nicht aber es muss ihm geben ich
habe nur noch nicht lange genug
nachgefroren Musik gehen das sagt jetzt
zumindest bleiben
unsere Freiheiten muss diesen Satz
unterliegen sie darf aber jetzt nicht zu
dem Satz von Grunde unterliegen dass die
Gründe und Freiheit die Freiheit
zerstören sind in der Notwendigkeit das
ist jetzt damit nicht gesagt nur sind
inklinationen also geneigt machen aber
nicht nötige es könnte also auch ganz
anders sein ist immer noch Kontinen
ja der Wille sagt jetzt Leidens auf der
anderen Seite also muss begründet sein
der Wille muss immer den Satz von Grunde
unterliegen auf der anderen Seite darf
aber der Wille nicht so verstanden
werden als wie er sagt irgendein
unerhörtes und sinnloses Vermögen ohne
Grund zu handeln oder nicht zu handeln
also indifferenzieren ein solch eine
solche Freiheit die würde auf einem wie
er sagt wieder natürlichen Vermögen
einer gewissen Maßen vernünftigen
Unvernunft basieren
nach leiden sind wir wenn wir den
Freiheit sind nicht
nettisiert oder liegen nicht den Zwang
wir sind aber trotzdem determiniert das
heißt Gründe spielen eine Rolle deshalb
von Grunde der gilt für unsere Handlung
und das bedeutet der Satz des gründes
schließt aus dass wir grundlos handeln
nämlich Indifferenz haben dass wir aus
bloße in der Generation Unbestimmtheit
heraus handeln das wäre verleibnitz auch
nicht mit willenseits vertreten
Leibniz Vertrieb also einen
kompatibilismus kompatibel heißt etwas
ist miteinander vereinbar verträglich er
vertritt ein kompatibilismus von
determination und Willensfreiheit
Freiheit muss gerade nach Leibnitz
detailliert sein weil sie sonst nicht
verständlich wäre und dem Satz des zu
reichenden Kundes sowie der laufen aber
mit der termination bedeutet eben nicht
dass sie die Freiheit unmöglich macht
sondern dass sie immer noch Kontingenz
also nicht Notwendigkeit in unseren
Entscheidung erlaubt
jetzt gab es natürlich da viel Kritik
wieso sollten wir in unserem Handeln in
unserem bildungsfreien Handeln die im
Satz von zu reichenden Gründe
unterliegen und da vollständig
detailliert sein physische und
moralische determination und auch das
physische ist der terminiert genauso wie
unser moralische es handelt und Immanuel
Kant hat das kritisiert diese
leibnitzsche der terministische
kompatibilistische
bildungsfreiheitstiere
hat gesagt wenn die Freiheit unseres
Willens keine andere als die letzte von
Leibnitz wäre so würde sie im Grunde
nicht besser als die Freiheit eines
raten wenn das sein der auch wenn er
einmal aufgezogen worden von selbst
seine Bewegungen berichtet sind wir also
praktisch nur
ratenwände kennen Sie vielleicht ein
bratenländer was ist ein Bratenwender
ist ein Spieß
auf dem
irgendein leckerer Braten steckt sie
könnte es vegan vegetarisch oder
fleischlich sich vorstellen Immanuel
Kant hat es natürlich sich fleischlich
vorgestellt und hat gedacht da ist ein
Spanferkel dran sie können aber
natürlich auch einen großen Maiskolben
reinspannen oder ein sonstiges Bratgerät
ne dass man heute mal völlig
dahingestellt und der bratenwende ist
ein Spieß der sich ganz langsam dreht
damit das was auf dem Spieß steckt und
spanferkelt dass das schön gebräunt wird
und gebraten wird weil sich der Spieß
dreht und da drunter ist ein Feuer also
gleichmäßig dreht sich der Partner sie
kennen das glaube ich noch ein Asterix
und Obelix da gibt's dann immer so eine
Stelle wo dann jemand so drehen muss
noch so das Schwein am Spieß glaube
die essen ja sehr viel Wildschwein dort
da muss immer jemand drehen aber es gibt
eben in dieser Zeit diese Aufklärung
oder ja aufklär vielleicht noch früh
Aufklärung gab es eben schon mechanische
Vorstellung dass man das mit einer
Triebfeder oder einer Spannung oder
irgendwie auch immer als einem
mechanischen Energiespeicher dass man
das eben dann automatisch drehen lässt
ja also Immanuel Kant kritisiert ist und
sagt was der Leibnitz uns erzählt mir
der termination da sind wir eigentlich
nur geistige Automaten ja spirituelle
Automaten die definiert sind die
vollständige trainiert sind und das
können wir nicht als Freiheit an
das beträgt sich nicht das sagt jetzt
die Manuel kann ja und jetzt bringe ich
ihn hier noch mal bekannt und möchte ihn
mal jetzt seine Gegenthese dazu
vorstellen also
Leibnitz hat versucht Willensfreiheit zu
denken
und zwar wollte er verschiedene
Anforderungen gerecht werden
Willensfreiheit muss immer dem Satz von
Kunde unterstehen Freiheit muss immer
begründet sein also Freiheit muss ihre
Gründe haben frei darf nichts
indifferentes
ja aber in dieser Form des Determinismus
wie Leibnitz in einem sind wir nur
geistige Automaten oder menschliche
bratenwände was auch immer jetzt da
drauf ist das ist nicht das ist nicht
wirklich Freiheit deswegen führt jetzt
jemand einen anderen
willenseits Begriff ein Gewicht in der
Autonomie
und zwar unter Autonomie versteht Manuel
Kanti Selbstgesetzgebung also von
griechisch Autos und Nomos sie kennen
alle das Wort Automobil das heißt
selbstbewegendes und mobilis ist aber
natürlich ein lateinisches Wort das
heißt es ist zusammen bei Autos und
Nomos dieses ganz ähm griechisch am
Selbstgesetzgebung ist das Gesetz und
jetzt bestimmt Manuel Kant die Autonomie
folgendermaßen sagt die Autonomie des
Willens ist die Beschaffenheit des
Willens dadurch derselbe ihm selbst
unabhängig von aller Beschaffenheit der
Gegenstände Wollens ein Gesetz ist das
Prinzip der Autonomie ist also nicht
anders zu wählen als so dass die
maximens seiner Wahl in demselben wollen
zugleich als allgemeines Gesetz
mitbegriffen sei ruhig das ist jetzt
wieder typisch sind und sehr kompliziert
das kommt Ihnen sicherlich bekannt vor
wenn Sie hier mal schauen dass allgemein
Gesetz
kategorischer Imperativ haben wir schon
mal gehört also das Gesetz von dem kann
dir spricht bei der Autonomie bei der
Selbstgesetzgebung ist nicht ein
beliebiges Gesetz was wir uns geben
sondern es ist nichts geringeres als der
Sittengesetz das moralische Gesetzes wie
es eben durch den kategorischen
Imperativ ausgedrückt ist und der
kategorisch Imperativ fordert dass wir
unsere Maximen verallgemeinern ja dass
wir die Maximen vernünftig wählen so
dass sie ein allgemeines Gesetz werden
können wir hatten das ein Beispiel der
Lüge diskutiert der Noten
jetzt ist also praktisch das Gesetz der
Autonomie nicht irgendein eingesetzt
sondern es ist unser eigenes Gesetz weil
ich könnte jetzt ja immer sagen
dieses Gesetz was ich mit der geben
sollte Sittengesetz das ist gar nicht
mein Gesetz sondern das ist irgendein
moralisches Gesetz was mit der
vorgegeben wurde mit dem ich mich gar
nicht identifizieren kann
und wenn das so wäre dass sie die Gesetz
wenn es nicht mein Gesetz wäre dann wäre
es ja nicht Autonomie das heißt ja
selbst Gesetzgebung das heißt ich muss
mir nicht nur selbst eingesetzt geben
streng genommen das könnte ja irgendwie
ein Gesetz sein was mir gar nicht passt
und der ist immer noch von mir selbst
gegeben aber es wäre nicht im starken
sind Autonomie sondern dieses Gesetz was
mir selbst gebe das muss auch noch mein
eigenes Gesetz sein ja also nicht ich
gebe mir nicht ein fremdes Gesetz
sondern ich gebe mir ein gesetzliches
mein eigenes Gesetz ist das heißt es
Sittengesetz ist nach Kant eigentlich
mein eigenes Gesetz
jetzt wird natürlich spannend wie soll
denn das Sittengesetz mein eigenes
Gesetz sein ja was hat was hat denn ich
mit der Moral zu tun ja ich wieso sollte
ich das Sittengesetz als mein eigenes
Gesetz annehmen können im Handel kann es
hat aber dass das Sittengesetz
eigentlich Ausdruck unseres wahren
Selbst ist also wenn wir unseren Willen
und es wieder Willen wenn wir unseren
Willen nur genau prüfen und sind wählen
genau untersuchen also wie schon gesagt
zurücktreten von unseren Neigungen und
und überlegen was will ich eigentlich ne
das ist ja die Frage die wir uns was
will ich eigentlich was soll das Gesetz
meine Handlungen zeigen was soll meine
Maxime sein was sollen meinetwegen sein
im Leben dann sagt immer man kann nicht
nur ganz wenn ich nur genug zurücktreten
und meinen wollen kritisch hinterfragen
dann komme ich wenn ich lang genug
überlege und das dauert noch gar nicht
so dann komme ich drauf dass ich
eigentlich immer das Sittengesetz will
dass ich eigentlich im Grunde immer
moralisch hat dass das moralische Gesetz
eigentlich mein wesensgesetz ich sage
manche Forscher also mein Innerstes
ausdrückt mein Innerstes innersten
meines Willens will ich eigentlich immer
das Gute sagt Immanuel Kant ja das kann
man natürlich jetzt beschreiben aber es
ist trotzdem irgendwie plausibel
natürlich wenn ich nur genug nachdenke
dann wäre der beste Grund für mein
Handel dass ich gut habe dass ich
praktisch die Menschheit verbessere dass
ich das Leid maximiere dass ich mich an
moralische Gründe halten und könnte
schon sagen guten Gründe also wenn ich
meine Gründe untersuche die mich
motivieren könnten dann sind die besten
Gründe die guten Gründe sind die
moralischen können ja gute Gründe sind
eigentlich moralische Gründe also muss
das was meinen Willen stimmt oder mein
handelt bestimmt die Moral sein und die
Moral wird eben so ausgedrückt wie der
kategorische Imperativ ist befiehlt
jetzt geht es natürlich hier einige
kritische Rückfragen ja wollen wir
eigentlich immer das was das
Sittengesetz befiehlt sind wir im
tiefsten Inneren eigentlich wesentlichen
moralisch ist unser besseres selbst
unser besseres ich bekannt sagt ist das
eigentlich ein moralisches ich unser
eigentliches Licht und es ist nur
umgeben von Schichten die wir praktisch
wie eine Zwiebel abschälen müssen ja von
Schichten des Egoismus von Schichten der
eigene und der der
Selbstliebe und müssen wir diese
Schichten abblättern und kommt dann am
Ende wenn wir alle Willens Schichten
abgetragen haben am Ende der wahren
moralische Kerne raus das kann man
natürlich in Frage stellen und das haben
natürlich auch viele Fragen gestellt
und es gibt auch noch andere Probleme
der Autonomie ein Problem ist zum
Beispiel wie können wir uns aus Freiheit
ein Gesetz geben auch wenn es unser
eigenes Gesetz ist wenn wir doch immer
schon unter einem Gesetz stehen müssen
um frei zu sein
ja also Freiheit ist noch kein
willensfeld heißt nach Kant Autonomie
selbst Gesetzgebung aber wir müssen doch
uns erst ein Gesetz geben um frei zu
sein in welchem Zustand geben wir uns
das Gesetz
es kann ja nicht der Zustand der
Freiheit sein indem wir uns das Gesetz
geben weil wir ja erst dann frei sind
wenn wir schon unter einem Gesetz stehen
also wie ist dieser Zustand des sich
gesetzgebens zu verstehen weil
normalerweise werden wir ja jetzt frei
wenn der Sittengesetz schon unsere
Gesetz ist unter dem also diese Aktien
selbst eingesetzt zu geben und ihm dann
auch zu folgen der ist irgendwie
unbestimmt ja das irgendwie so eine
Lücke diese Aktie sich das Gesetz zu
geben der steht ja noch nicht unter dem
Gesetz wir müssen ja erst uns um das
Gesetz bringen wenn wir unter dem Gesetz
stehen ist alles okay aber wir müssen ja
erst mal das ist ein Gesetz geben und
diese dieser Moment der ist unbestimmt
das irgendwie problematisch das ist
häufig auch als paradox der Autonomie
bezahlen kann
weiteres Problem ist wenn das autonome
gesetzt das sieht ein Gesetz ist wenn
das also unser eigenes Ich ausdrückt wie
können wir uns dann
Ökonomen gegen das Sittengesetz und für
das Orangen
ist doch ein Faktum dass viele Menschen
aus Freiheit das Böse tun oder
unmoralisch handeln und dafür auch zu
Verantwortung gezogen werden dass man
sagt das ist ihre Verantwortung sie
selbst haben sich so bestimmt dass sie
gegen das sieben Gesetz gehandelt haben
das perfekte Verbrechen ein Banküberfall
natürlich weiß die Räuberin der Räuber
dass das was er tut oder sie tut
unmoralisch ist aber es gibt eben andere
Interessen und man hat die Tendenz
sozusagen diese Menschen die ihren
Banküberfall durchführen die machen das
aus vollster Freiheit weil sie auch
anders hätten handeln können sie haben
sich dafür entschieden und deswegen
werden sie wenn sie geschnappt werden
auch vor Gericht gestellt
ja aber wie ist jetzt diese Freiheit zu
verstehen ein Banküberfall zu begehen
im Sinne der Autonomie wir geben uns
doch da gerade nicht der Sittengesetz
die unterstehen doch gerade nicht im 7
gesetzt wenn wir ein Banküberfall
Unternehmen ja ist das dann überhaupt
noch ein freies Handeln wenn das doch
nicht mehr dem 7 Gesetz untersteht sind
wir dann nicht mehr frei wenn wir böse
haben aber auf der anderen Seite werden
wir doch dafür zu rechenbarkeit gezogen
wie steht das mit diesem unmoralischen
Handeln es ist ein großes Problem für
die Autonomie
ja wir haben jetzt gleich noch eine
Diskussionsrunde ich möchte aber
trotzdem noch verändert der Vorlesung
ein weiteres Thema noch bringen wir
haben jetzt sehr viele spannende Themen
da kann man treffen dann auch in der
nächsten Vorlesung und natürlich in den
Tutorial noch weiter diskutieren weil
die Freiheit ein wir unerschöpfliches
Thema ist jetzt kommen wir noch ein
bisschen auf das Thema kompatibilismus
und inkompatibilismus zu sprechen wir
haben das schon mal gehört ich hatte
vorhin gesagt Leibnitz vertreten eine
kompatibilistische freiheitstheorie weil
er der Meinung ist das Willensfreiheit
und der termination sind nicht
ausschließen sondern dass sie den Streit
gerade determination braucht aber nicht
Notwendigkeit
so jetzt bringe ich Ihnen mal die
Definition die ist allgemein anerkannt
kompatibilismus und Blick auf
Willensfreiheit heißt Willensfreiheit
ist mit der termination vereinbar
Leibniz ist zum Beispiel ein solcher
Vertreter einer der klassischen
Kompatibilität der Willensfreiheit für
die Handlungsfreiheit ist
kompatibilismus gar kein Problem
eigentlich können alle Theoretikerin und
Theoretiker der Handlungsfreiheit sagen
wir sind kompatibilistisch weil wir
gehen ja nur von dem Willen aus und
fragen wenn er da ist er will kann in
eine andere umgeführt umgesetzt werden
welche Gründe den genau bestimmt haben
interessieren uns ja
Handlungsfreiheit betrachtet ja nicht
die Frage wie der Wille zustande
gekommen ist sondern nur ob der Wille
existiert in einer Hand geführt werden
kann das heißt der Wille selbst kann
ganz verschieden deziminationen
unterliegen
sofern in ein anderes wird ist alles
wunderbar das heißt
handlungs-theoretikerinnen Theoretiker
der Freiheit
Handlungsfreiheit Theoretikerin und
Theoretiker die vertreten meistens ohne
Probleme ein kompatibel ist der Wille
kann verschiedentlich bestimmt sein ist
egal
bei der Willensfreiheit wird die Frage
nach dem kompatibilismus noch viel viel
drängender
also kompanibismus heißt wenn es weit
ist mit der termination vereinbar und
ich hatte schon gesagt Leibnitz ist
einer der
Hauptvertreter diese Auffassung also
Beispiel wäre man könnte sagen gründete
terminiert unsere handeln aber Gründe
sind nicht naturkauslei Ursachen so
könnte man versuchen ein diesen
kompatibilismus zu begründen ja man
könnte sagen wir sind deswegen
determiniert in unserem freien Hand und
weil ja die Gründe hatte ich ja gebracht
verschiedene rollende Gründe weil ja
immer Gründe eine Rolle spielen und
gründete Termine und handeln also ist
Freiheit mit kompatibilismus ist
kompatibilistisch zu verstehen natürlich
gibt sie große Probleme wenn sie sagen
ja gründete Termine und behandeln aber
nicht die Naturgesetze da kann man sich
fragen ja wie verhalten sich denn jetzt
Gründe des freien Handel zu den
Naturgesetzen stehen irgendwie außerhalb
der Naturgesetze oder sind Sie
zusätzliche Naturgesetze ja also ein
riesen Problem wie man solche Gründe und
die willenseit mit der Natur
gesetzlichen determination unseres
Körpers der ganzen Welt in eine Einheit
bringen kann weil wenn man jetzt sagt es
gibt aber Gründe die nicht
naturgesetzlich gelten dann liegt es
nahe einen nebenwelt zu erschaffen eine
Welt der Gründe die neben der Welt der
Naturgesetze existiert dann hat man so
ein Dualismus und es bringt uns auch
nicht viel wenn man da noch hingeben
will irgendwie eröffnen ja wir müssen
doch alle in derselben Welt frei handeln
ja wo auch die Naturgesetze ja das ist
man könnte sonst natürlich auch sagen ja
die Naturgesetz sie haben gewisse
Unbestimmtheiten gewisse Lücken
wir sollten Naturgesetze nicht so stark
an einem schwächeren abgeschwächten also
eine Strategie des Determinismus das
kompatibilismus ist sagen ja die
Naturgesetze die gelten nicht ganz so
streng also der terminismus ist ein
weicher Determinismus weil der
templinismus nicht hart ist hart heißt
das vollständig gnadenlos ein weicher
der terminismus der lässt das irgendwie
noch zu dass ich da unsere Freiheit noch
einträgt in diesem Kontext ja man
spricht von einem weichen der
terminismus man muss also in der
terminismus Abschminken um ein
kompatibilismus vertreten zu werden
großes Problem wie man in der thermismus
so abschwächen kann das Freiheit oder
spezielle noch möglich ist
also wie können wir die Realität von
Gründen erklären auch angesichts der
Naturgesetzen das ist ein Problem dieses
kompatibilismus
dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite noch
den inkompatibilismus und
Inkompatibilität muss heißt ganz
allgemein gesagt willenseits mit der
termination nicht vereinbar
daraus kann jetzt aber verschiedenes
folgen
daraus kann erstmal folgen dass wir weil
es Freiheit nicht mit der termination
vereinbar ist und der Determinismus war
ist
folgt dass wir nicht willensfrei sind
also wenn inkompatibilismus bedeutet
entweder also Willensfreiheit ist mit
der dimenation nicht vereinbart dann
gilt die Frage was ist jetzt wahr ist
jetzt die determination war mit der
terminismus war oder ist er falsch wenn
man sagte Determinismus ist wahr dann
folgt daraus dass wie ein harten
Determinismus vertreten also der
terminismus ist wahr und deswegen sind
wir nicht frei weil wir alles ganz
strikte terminiert ist durch die
Naturgesetze also kann unser billig gar
nicht frei sein der ist evolutionär
bedingt und der lässt sich zurück zu
folgen in der Kausalkette bis zum
urknallen ja jetzt sind die Kausalketten
die dahin Gang gesetzt wurden die würden
heute noch machen also wir können
theoretisch alles genau berechnen ja was
wir jetzt tun was ich ihm jetzt sage ist
sowieso
bestimmt gewesen ja
die Gründe meines jetzigen Handelns die
sind eigentlich Ursachen die vor meine
Geburt zurückreichen das heißt ich bin
nicht Herr meiner Handlung im Sinne der
willensfreiheiten das nennt man auch das
Konsequenz Auge Peter von invegen ein
ganz bekannter analytischer Philosoph
wieder von denen heute auch noch ein
bisschen was erzählen werde der hat
gesagt die Gründe meines Handelns und
die bestimmenden Faktoren meines
Handelns oder auch meines Wollens liegen
in der Vergangenheit liegen vor meiner
Geburt das heißt ich kann nicht dafür
verantwortlich sein für mein Handeln das
er ist zwar kein harte detektivist aber
er bringt dieses Argument also ein harte
detektivist würde so argumentieren ne
die Gründe die Ursachen bei unseres
Handelns die sind schon vor unsere
Geburt angelegt gewesen haben also sind
frei für das was wir jetzt tun wir sind
bloße ja bloße Natur Ereignisse
letztendlich
ja und dann ist natürlich das Problem
wir sind dann nicht mehr für unsere
Handlung verantwortlich also der Begriff
der Verantwortung der Begriff des
moralisch guten wie bösen Macht in der
herkömmlichen Weise dann keinen Sinn
mehr
man kann dann irgendwie noch anders
drüber reden gibt eine große Diskussion
auch in der Hirnforschung manche
hirnforscherinnenorgane Städten wird wir
sind nur dasjenige was im Gehirn vor
sich geht und Gehirn finden Prozesse
statt die gar nicht unter unsere
Kontrolle stehen ich komme der nächsten
Sitzung auf die sogenannten lippet
Experimente von Benjamin zu sprechen der
sagt bevor wir bewusst eine Entscheidung
fällen hat im Gehirn schon die
Entscheidung stattgefunden ohne dass wir
uns dessen bewusst waren solche
Auffassung gibt's auch es gibt also
verschiedene Spielarten das haben der
terminismus z.B auch auf hirnorganisch
dass man sagt wir sind selbst nur
neuronale Schaltung unsere
Handlungen sind neuronale Prozesse die
gar nicht unsere willentlichen Kontrolle
unterliegt das ist der harte
Determinismus dann gibt es aber das
Problem dass wir dann Moral und Freiheit
und Zuschreibungen und moralisch gut und
böse eigentlich gar nicht mehr adäquat
verwenden können weil wir gar nicht
dafür verantwortlich sind wir können
keinen Menschen mehr Vorwürfe machen für
das was sie tun und wir können Sie auch
gar nicht loben sondern wir müssen sagen
ach du hast Glück gehabt mit dir hat der
Urknall sich sofort gesetzt dass du
irgendwie jetzt
einfach mit unserer Gesellschaft besser
kooperiert und einem
Bankräuber muss man sagen auch du hast
einfach Pech gehabt der Urknall hat sich
in dir so bemerkbar gemacht dass du
einfach mit unserem Gesetzen Konflikt
kommst aber es bedauerlich aber du
kannst ja nichts dafür
und ist die Frage ob das wirklich unser
Selbstverständnis widerspiegelt so eine
Rede ja also wir müssen auf ganz viel
verzichten und unsere gesellschaftliche
Ordnung würde natürlich so nicht mehr
haltbar sein Verbrecherin Verbrecher
müsste man natürlich ins Gefängnis
stecken aber nicht deswegen weil sie
eine wirklich Untat begangen haben
sondern um einfach die Gesellschaft für
ihn zu schützen ja also diese Defekte
Wesen wo einfach irgendwie die Maschine
nicht ganz richtig funktioniert die
Menschenwürde können sich vorstellen die
bleibt dabei natürlich auch irgendwie
bisschen auf der Strecke
ja aber das möchte ich nur so ein
bisschen anreißen wir diskutieren das
noch weiter das ist also eine Option der
das im kompatibilismus dass wir sagen
lebensfreiheit ist mit der termination
unvereinbar weil der Determinismus war
ist ja daraus folgt die den zweiten ist
falsch es gibt aber noch die
entgegengesetzte Position die sagt wir
vertreten in kompatibilismus und zwar
deswegen weil der determination mit der
Determinismus falsch ist und deswegen
sind wir frei ja also wir dürfen nicht
davon ausgehen dass wir uns frei und der
termination miteinander vereinbar sind
und zwar deswegen weil wenn das der Fall
wäre dann wäre ich denkbar so wie der
harte detailismus daraus muss dann aber
folgen dass der Determinismus falsch ist
also deswegen ist praktisch sind frei
weil
ist falsch und deswegen sind wir wenn es
Problem natürlich wie immer gibt es da
naturgesetzliche Lücken als wo das
Naturgesetz einfach nicht gilt
ist dann Freiheit mit dem
Indeterminismus vereinbar aus einem
libertarierismus folgt häufig der
endeterminismus also die These das wir
gar nicht irgendwie der terminiert sind
in unserem Handeln und auch das ist
eigentlich ihr kontraintuitiv weil wir
doch immer sagen müssen wir haben Gründe
für unsere Handel und Gründe bestimmen
unser Handeln und sie haben wir haben
schon drüber gesprochen die
Indifferenz des unbestimmte das verträgt
sich auch nicht mit unsere Intuition von
Handlung sie wollen immer fragen warum
hast du es getan und nicht einfach doch
es ist einfach so passiert ne es gibt
neuere Auffassung die sagen dass eben im
Hirn in unserem Gehirn Quanten Zustände
für unsere Freiheit entscheiden sind und
Quanten zuständig sind natürlich die
Zustände die auf Wahrscheinlichkeit
passieren wurde Zufall auch eine Rolle
spielt die nicht strengende
terrinistisch sind so kann man das
versuchen naturalistisch zu erklären
aber das Problem ist eben dass wir da
auch unbefriedigt sind weil wir wollen
nicht sagen ich habe das getan weil da
ein Quantenzustand der Arzt x war und da
eine Unbestimmtheit war sie wollen an
Grund nennen deswegen habe ich getan
weil das sind das und das sind das ja
also das ist so ein bisschen das Problem
da haben sie jetzt eigentlich alle
Positionen es gibt aber auch noch eine
andere Position und die wird
mysterianismus genannt also die besagt
willensfrei ist ein Mysterium
da gibt es hier ein sehr gutes Buch die
Oxford Hand book of free will schon der
Second Edition
auch da kann ich so einige Texte auf
Ilias stellen und zwar ist dieser
Vertreter der
amerikanische Philosoph Peter und der
hat folgendes gesagt auf Englisch
sind we are face with the Mistry for
free will an die this and it all the
seems to be incom
ist weil auch nicht kompatibel wer ist
to say we are face with the Mistry is
the comparable in the time is also
freiheit ist ein Mysterium weil sowohl
sie nicht kompatibel ist mit
Determinismus als auch mit
Indeterminismus aber sie existiert
trotzdem ja wir müssen an der Freiheit
Essen und deswegen ist eigentlich
Freiheit ein Mysterium wir können es
eigentlich gar nicht genau begründen wir
müssen nur davon ausgehen dass es sie
gibt wir sind gezwungen sie anzunehmen
weil einfach so viele Intuitionen dafür
sprechen ja jetzt habe ich hier viel
geredet und sie erinnern sich noch an
meine Frage die ich am Anfang gestellt
hatte sind wir denn jetzt nach all dem
was ich Ihnen jetzt hier aus der
Geschichte der Philosophie bisschen neue
Zeit erzählt habe sind wir denn jetzt
eigentlich willensfrei oder nicht und
darüber können Sie jetzt kurz abstimmen
ich denke die Sache sollte noch online
sein
ja wir haben gesehen die Umfrage brachte
zu Tage 60% ungefähr sind der Meinung
wir sind willensfrei und 40% bisschen
mehr war der Auffassung wir sind nicht
willensfreies gibt gute Argumente dafür
dagegen ich hatte schon gesagt die
freiheitsdebatte ist noch heutzutage ein
hart und kämpftes Feld es ist eine der
entscheidenden der vielleicht
wichtigsten Debatten der ganzen
Philosophie seit Jahrhunderten
vielleicht sogar seit Jahrtausenden sie
wird nach wie vor weiter diskutiert und
sie wird auch so schnell nicht enden
weil so viele Fragen damit zusammen
Fragen nach der ganzen Beschaffenheit
der Welt aber auch nach der
Beschaffenheit von uns selbst da gehen
so viele andere Fragen noch mit einem
diese freiheitsdebatte deswegen ist der
freiheitsbericht von ganz zentrale
Begriff den ich auch in meinem Begriff
setzt noch ein bisschen hervorheben
werde jetzt gebe ich ganz pünktlich zum
Ende der heutigen Sitzung noch ein
Ausblick auf die nächste Vorlesung wir
werden darin noch das Thema
Sprachhandlungen oder Sprechakte
behandelt wir haben ja gesagt wir müssen
verschiedene Arten von Handlung
diskutieren der Grundgedanke ist die
Handeln nicht nur durch den Einsatz
unserer Hände wie es ja Handeln
suggeriert sondern auch durch den
Einsatz unserer Sprache wir können also
auch sprachhandlung vollziehen
Handlungen als Sprechakte auffassen also
sprach Handlungen sprich Akte ein
Beispiel für Sprechakte der
sprachhandlung ist zum Beispiel befehlen
er nennen oder Taufe wenn ich sage ich
ernenne dich hiermit zum Ritter
Ehrenlegion oder keine Ahnung dann
wo ich da eigentlich nicht viel ich sag
da so fünf sechs Wörter eine besonders
feierlichen Stil vielleicht ja aber die
Person zu der ich das sage die ist
danach eine andere Person die hat danach
ganz andere Rechte Pflichten für die
ändert sich sehr viel also mit so ein
paar Worten kann ich das Leben einer
Person grundlegend verändern und nicht
nur indem ich sie beleidige oder den
Kompliment machen sind die mich
irgendwie offiziell
in einer bestimmten Funktion sie zu
etwas
kaufen ja auf einen Namen Taufen aber
auch Befehlen
kann ich wenn ich in der richtigen
Funktion bin ich kann natürlich häufig
fehlen wenn ich nicht in der richtigen
Funktion bin dann tut sich gar nichts ja
der geht natürlich immer verschiedene
unternah mit rein unter gewissen
Umständen kann ich mit meiner Sprache
wenn es reglementiert ist sozial sehr
sehr viel tun ich finde immer noch das
beste das ernennen ja wenn man jemanden
ernennt durch den sprechaktes ernennens
das wird häufig noch sprachlich getan
man kann natürlich auch eine Person ein
Ernennungsurkunde zusenden aber es geht
in bestimmten Kontexten noch durch
sprachhandlung das finde ich sehr
spannend weil das sollte man nicht außer
Acht lassen dazu gibt es ein sehr
wichtiges Buch von Austin einem ebenso
analytischen Behörden mit dem Titel how
to do things with words also wie können
wir Dinge tun durch Worten was können
wir durch unsere Sprache alles bewirken
durch unsere Sprache ja dann sind wir
ganz pünktlich am Ende angelangt ich
bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
freue mich auf die nächste sitzen und
der wird dann ganz viel diskutiert
werden